first question for throwing towards the
center huh dream on Rick total of 95 7
the game and sports byline right here in
the middle coach Kerr was just talking
about how not much pride you guys have
and you've been on top of the mountain
for two years and these guys trying to
knock you off and take the crown how
much does that pride you know just take
that next game one at a time when you
know someone's trying to take that crown
from you um I mean that's important you
know that I probably had a faith in what
we're capable of
like said she's got to take it one game
at a time we got to win one game we win
one then we'll build on that you know
but I've been on the wrong side of three
one before so why not make our own
history on Jeff Verado Bay Area News
Group Steve was just in here talking
about the intensity that you guys played
with defensively in the first half and
you in particular what do you think the
difference wasn't there what do you
think the difference was in the second
half did you get you guys get tired or
they just started executing differently
I think they made shots you know our
defense is flying around I think we
still got some good contest enter the
second half like you know started to
have and I have two great contestant on
Kauai 3-0 you know and then they found a
rhythm and you don't wants a team like
that finds a rhythm it's hard to take
them out of it is very good obviously
did that seem to give them open shots at
times and leave you guys a half a step
behind uh I mean their ball movement has
been great um you know I think our
rotations tonight was better but you
know I've still got to get better so
came in the back left dream on Tim
Reynolds with the associated press two
questions one how difficult is it to try
to rattle a guy like Kauai who just
doesn't really get rattled ever and - do
you have any hope that KD can get out
there on Monday and how hard would that
be farm after not playing for a month I
mean I don't think you're ever gonna
rattle Kauai you know not sure we use
that where at one time in our Scott
report
you know rattle him but you know you
just try to make them take tough shots
and you live with the results and as far
as Katie utters been hoping he will come
back to whole series so you know that's
not going to change now obviously we
hope to album but you know we'll see
what happens you know we don't make that
final call is she he don't really even
make that final call his body will tell
him if he can get out there or not and
if he can great if not you still gotta
try to find a way to win in next game
serger over here
CJ Peters in the San Francisco Examiner
obviously Co wise 20 perks you mean 36
is gonna you know get a lot of the
headlines today but serge ibaka 20
really hurts you guys he was a slim
screens in the pick-and-roll what was so
hard about him to guard tonight and why
did he find so much success country as a
defense well I think um you know our we
kind of messed up our coverages a little
bit on him but Chicago was kraid not
some shots down some like every game he
missed somebody else you know Danny
Green in Game three then we completely
take him at the end night and surge and
so we just like I said we gotta win one
game and you know however we got to get
that done
start with that and you know go from
there
Henry forth from the fourth row on the
right Henry I have a true dream on can
you narrate that chase-down block on T
outcome and whatever happened following
it Robert was it Lowry no I thought it
was Lowry there you go that's the play I
want to talk about I kind of got a head
start on me I was turning this brain but
just tried to make a play on the ball
was able to get the block and then knock
the rebound away from C Ackerman we've
you know going back to other way we
still lost though so I really don't
matter mark on this second left
dream on mark Schwartz ESPN on your left
earlier in the series you were talking
about Kauai that he doesn't look like
you know KD or LeBron or Lillard when he
scores 36 points but he still gets a
tiny
come into the league as a natural scorer
when he does this kind of stuff in a
game like this what impression do you
leave about what this guy's effect is on
this series he still don't look like the
ho but he still getting it done you
gotta give him his credit uh you know he
he he imposed this world on the game you
know and you know I look at other guys
follow them so I'm not sure if it'll
ever look like those other guys but he
get the job done so you got to go from
credit for Dan back right Dan Devine
from the ringer you guys have delivered
so many of those big punches in third
quarters before tonight you're on the
receiving end of one as that's happened
and as you sort of feeling the game go
the other way what are you thinking and
you know how you trying to sort of claw
back in those moments ah this sucks you
know
sucks really bad you know are you just
trying to do whatever you can to change
it you know to get a stop you know get a
bucket get some momentum every time we
did you know they answered you know yeah
sucked a lot but can't get it back now
a ver date last question over there
draymond Akina lotto Gazzetta Italy
you're the heart and soul of the
Warriors I'm pretty sure Luke your
teammates in the eyes when you guys went
back in the locker room what did you see
and as a leader what do you think you
can do you know to motivate your team my
to keep guys head up keep God's belief
up you know God win three games in a row
we've won three God win three games in a
row we've won three games in a row
before you know however you gotta get
that done you just got to get it done
but you know just talk to the guys don't
watch you know the TV like just believe
what we believe and you know go out
there and give it what we got and if we
fail you live with the results you know
and if we fail you live with the results
you know but just leave it all out there